[Music]
in literally no time news submitted by
ice cream for sour cream and Norway
Island wants to be the world's first
time free zone should know how many time
yeah I guess I'm free that is my dream
oh my god every day I'm like I wish
there was no time like just but you're
lying because time is doing no actually
your lights yourself time is an illusion
it's relative I get it yeah but they're
how you're gonna fly how you gonna make
plans I think we're all assuming can you
see me whenever when the Sun looks like
that's exactly what time is based off of
you would never celebrate I see you when
I see you you anniversaries and
birthdays you would never celebrate that
wouldn't be attached to such material
things cuz there's no time we just
celebrate what we want to that come see
me when it's dark
that's where all right Alice in
Wonderland over there yeah yeah ask my
daydreams like I'm like [ __ ] that would
be so much better if we just got people
gifts when we felt like it and not like
because we had to cuz it's their
birthday or something maybe it would
mean more you know like is there like no
brakes like you know when you get into
work you get into work whenever it's all
a break like I don't understand like how
is that gonna function is that what
they're saying here yeah this island in
Norway it's called summer Rae summer
right I don't know it's that that Oh
with the line through the middle I know
how to pronounce that but it means
summer Island and so they're saying from
May 18th to July 26th which is a full 69
days the Sun does not set freaky hmm it
never says 69 days of 69 cent that's
crazy that's your perfect scenario I
know it really is how do you like 60
I guess not only does No
nobody likes ya like saying poop I'm
holding on to being a child Eileen is
north of the Arctic Circle so during the
summer that's when they don't have any
nighttime at all and so because of that
they're saying that for generations and
generations and generations
every time that this time of the year
local people they do whatever the [ __ ]
they want so I got 2 a.m. they're
painting the house or at 4:00 a.m. they
go I love that this is out that's what
gives me anxiety is that I'm like oh
[ __ ] I only have three hours until it's
dark out I got to finish all this [ __ ]
before the Sun Goes Down I didn't like
during when it's not daylight savings
time and we only have like so few hours
of daylight five yeah I want to wake up
late I'm like [ __ ] I [ __ ] myself and I
get so much anxiety I guess no yeah but
no one's gonna be in sync you know like
so you know yeah people are like what
where's what's-his-face you like all
he's he's sleeping that's how you find
your tribe yeah I guess so at the same
time that construction I like 3:00 a.m.
when you're trying to sleep do you have
a schedule did they have it scheduled
out now so then they know that she's
gonna be [ __ ] up so everyone's [ __ ]
up all together
I don't like [ __ ] up I like order oh
my god we should go there and see how
you react kilter though what I'm just
saying is like like you have one group
of people who like they might sleep till
3:00 in the afternoon
yeah and then somebody else is up and
then you just never know when the
nighttime daytime is for all of us to
just be in oh so you'd have more FOMO
because you'd be like oh I might be
missing out yes yeah just like oh [ __ ]
it's what time is it you know
everybody's like we already leaving a
party yeah yeah that's one so I don't
know this is what it looks like
it's just a vacation island I get it if
it's prostitutes are like if I supposed
to be supposed to be a you know first of
all prostitution should not be on the
street anymore neither with the internet
you just like the window shop window
shop on the screen that's like buying
hotel porn nobody buys hotel why would
you buy hotel somebody's buying it cuz I
still got it
I don't know why you would do that just
get the internet people pay for either
one you should pay for the internet with
your computer it's definitely like 50
plus men yeah well people don't
understand that but the hotel point that
comes in movie format it's a different
experience brownson finish never good
it's not like it's good point it sounds
like you purchased it before no no I
travel a lot alright so here's some more
photos oh they're saying that there's
this bridge here that you know how
usually there will be like padlocks oh
yeah embolizing love but they put their
watches symbolizing like this is a time
free zone that's crazy
do they all run after like day 17 like
Fogerty my watch yes I'm sure it's not a
Rolex over there it's not an Apple watch
that's so cool so they still get sunset
views without having this is like my
dream yeah yeah yeah but that same place
also has like it like probably a time of
where it's nighttime all the time too
then right yeah oh you know and
depressing so that's why it during this
time of the year it's like they really
get the most out of the deal
they are just up and I'm like I don't
like at all time that's so dope trying
to sunbathing it whatever time line if
you want to start an energy drink
company go there when it's what is it
may BAM because we're gonna be running
on that [ __ ] all day long is it warm
there yeah was it Arctic you don't know
it would have to be more hours a day
this is Sun in the Antarctica there's
nothing like it's cold because people
are wearing hoodies
yes see suck it swimming so they're
saying that now they want they want to
officially make it the first place in
the world at the time free zone so
that's why they're petitioning for this
to be the first ever time free zone it's
all ridiculous bunch of hippies it's
ridiculous say you have a hotel like
you're not gonna have what are you not
gonna have any events you're not gonna
have breakfast you're not gonna have
like because it's like you have to you
have to set a time all day dinner yeah
it must be just a bluff day that's going
on all day edible there's no events
there's no because you can't be like um
we're gonna do an event when everybody
shows up no way new people get off them
right exactly
how do you know when to go to maybe they
don't care about such things
materialistic me as materialistic
schedules did you trade chickens and
that's it you know like they're fine
yeah but when do you trade the chickens
when the bell strikes to be half
somebody you're like yo you wanted to
just walking around your chicken and you
just hopefully another person is walking
with your chicken yeah because you want
orange oranges I got chickens in the
Train yeah you were just trading
chickens no
yes so they're saying that um so the
people are petitioning for this time
free zone and be official or saying to
many of us getting this in writing with
simply main form of formalizing
something we have been practicing
they've already been done so they're
hoping to be free of traditional opening
hours and introduced flexibility in
school and working hours who's anti this
it's like what that community decide for
itself they all agree they're like
people that have responsibilities then
someone bard way far away so for me it's
like you don't live there everyone oh
yeah I would never make another
community do what I feel is right like
they should do what they want to do what
if you're part of it but think about the
schools exactly when is after school
they train their kids however they want
to train their kids okay it's a free
little summer lands gonna be like home
schooling cuz it's like you know your
kid's gonna be like I'm off mom you know
when you talk about it it's over when
you learn math yeah yes that's when it's
over I've been to a place similar it's a
Edmonton in Canada and it was 11 o'clock
Edmonton yet and it looked like 3 p.m.
and the afternoon and I just see kids
like running around playing and I'm
looking at my watch I'm like this is
when the bad guys come out and then how
would you saw worry like I started
feeling anxious cuz I'm not used to I'm
used to like people closing the windows
and stuff like that in the whole world
shutting down people are just playing
like it's nothing people are jogging and
[ __ ] I might see they're happy what a
criminal's doing that say they probably
just like I guess I just got a rock they
go with the nocturnal at 7 a.m. yeah yet
it might pack up the raccoon no they
just go ahead Disick like you know imma
let you guys chill now but wait till
nighttime Co yeah and they're just
there's waiting for 69 days of 960 any
second the border we're still day dark
time yeah yeah that's a crosses oh yeah
I don't know it's kind of cool
yeah but also the school thing like it's
only during summer months anyway
yeah yeah but summer school don't you
might have this audition you want
there's no summer school there's no that
I guys I I just thinking about it makes
me anxious you open your mind up
thinking about it makes me feel like
what like so what on their phone it's
not gonna say anything like what is it
gonna just be like it's gonna do what
they're gonna be like don't worry yeah
don't worry about it
yeah what are the others gonna say I
don't know I don't know I don't like it
you should go visit then maybe check out
if you're betting she's about to go see
what they're doing with their lives
yeah I'll just be like now I'll be like
I'll just be yelling at everybody
[Laughter]
he's from the time land I think I'm
gonna get discriminated against
he's a timer I don't like it that's
really weird I wonder if these people
have kind of evolved to deal with that
because I imagine like if you it's kind
of like jet lag right yeah and like you
can never really get the right sleep or
like your body clock would be all off
well you get those blackout cut I'm just
gonna say that you can't blackout
curtains and then you just it doesn't
even matter because whenever you wake up
you can you get the day but I'm not
biologically your body needs to reset
right but like you know how those
daytime people and nighttime people like
and some people just operate better on
different hours of the day yeah the
whole world's like meant for like
society has structured around daytime
people which I happen to be a morning
person so that's great but I was always
jealous of people like a party all night
but in this world you can just wake up
whenever your body naturally likes to
wake up and you don't miss out on like
having a job that changes you you know
you know it's crazy like I have to sleep
fully blacked out curtains completely
cave yeah you could do that I'd be
[ __ ] no you can do that what they
don't have curtains when I can't lady
nighttime this little sliver I can't
stand that so get that once I go down
like this
it's a wall actually you need the ones
with the tracks go like this yeah that's
why you guys aren't invited to live
there she's gonna need a mayor of this
place the dark like how do you sleep
with blackout creep why might in the
dark as I'm knocked out she's just
praying in touch you fall asleep yeah oh
you don't wear the thing you don't have
a mask no we have blackout curtains are
we doing the trash but Ivan curtain sort
out but those are expensive trash bags
oh wait what would you put in foil
please put trash bags everywhere yeah
it's actually very effective it is a
prospective reefer just yeah
[Music]